à l'aéroport de hong kong un des plus
achalandées du monde c'était le retour à
la normale après les affrontements
violents des derniers jours entre la
police et les manifestants
après l'annulation de centaines de vols
les avions ont enfin pu décoller au
grand soulagement des voyageurs non
payés ils ne devraient pas manifester
ici nous allons finir par les blâmer et
10e voyageurs qui a dû patienter deux
jours avant de pouvoir s'enregistrer sur
un vol hébergement et se feront compris
eau pendant que le personnel médical et
infirmier des sept principaux hôpitaux
de hong kong protester contre la
brutalité policière qui a fait des
blessés au cours des jours précédents
l'accalmie s'est généralisé à toute la
vie excepté ces quelques centaines de
manifestants qui se sont rassemblées en
soirée devant un commissariat de police
ils ont utilisé des rayons laser pour
déjouer les policiers et brouillé leurs
caméras
les forces de l'ordre ont riposté en
tirant des gaz lacrymogènes
elles se sont aussi montrés plus
menaçante dispersez vous où on vous tire
dessus pouvait-on lire sur leurs
pancartes
mais c'est à pékin que le ton a monté de
plusieurs crans pour la première fois
les autorités ont qualifié les
manifestants d'un gang de terroristes
pioche souid janvier le château ils ont
dépassé les bornes de la loi de la
morale et de même les bornes de la
nature humaine
dix-sept animateurs de la télévision
chinoise en citant le porte parole du
bureau central de pékin responsable d'un
encore pour une des rares fois la
télévision chinoise faisait référence
aux événements de hong kong montrant un
vox pop très critique des manifestants
tout ce qu'ils veulent c'est
l'indépendance de encore dit cette jeune
traductrice de pékin alors que plusieurs
craignent de plus en plus une
intervention de l'armée chinoise
les autorités de pékin ont fait
largement circulé une nouvelle vidéo qui
montre l'entraînement de la police de la
chine continentale pour faire face aux
émeutes aussi menaçante et suggestive
que peuvent être ces images il n'est pas
dit qu'elles réussiront à dissuader ceux
qui réclament plus de démocratie en com
ici alexandre aja tic à radio canada
montréal